alors le non cumul des mandats va-t-il
changer le visage de ces élections
sénatoriales pour en parler thème
tranier nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
bonjour tu as marre qu'on est fils de
l'application et des conséquences de
l'application du non-cumul
je rappelle tout d'abord que cette loi
de février 2014 qui était portée par le
gouvernement de françois hollande
interdit de cumuler un mandat de
parlementaire c'est-à-dire de député ou
de sénateur avec une fonction exécutive
locale comme président de région de
département ou encore de mer et que
cette loi elle sera appliquée au sénat à
partir du début de la session prochaine
c'est à dire le 2 octobre prochain
d'après nos calculs et bien cette loi
elle impacte les élections sénatoriales
puisque une soixantaine de sénateurs 57
très exactement sur les 171
renouvelables sont concernés par cette
loi sur le non cumul des mandats alors
thème quels sont les sénateurs qui ont
abandonné leurs mandats locaux et qui
ont préféré privilégier leur mentent à
leur mandat
ici des sénateurs alors on va commencer
d'abord par ceux qui préfèrent conserver
donc leur mandat local ils sont 21 à ne
pas se représenter à ce au sénat et à
garder leur mandat exécutif local par
exemple et bien christian favier
sénateurs communistes qui préfèrent
rester président du conseil
départemental du val de marne
on peut également parler du côté des
élèves de christophe béchu qui
préféreraient y rester maire d'angers du
côté du groupe centriste le président du
groupe françois zocchetto choisi un
laval dit il on peut aussi penser qu'il
y a quelques raisons politiques par
exemple et bien le sénateur jean claude
lenoir une se représente pas aux
sénatoriales il est bien à la tête d'un
exécutif local mais sa décision est
motivée par le souci du renouvellement
et aussi à cause des divisions dans sa
famille politique de la droite
certains ont préféré se présenter se
représenter au sénat malgré tout et
selon nos calculs
eh bien ils sont 36 à se représenter et
donc à devoir abandonner leur mandat
exécutif local
prenez par exemple philippe bas
sénateurs les républicains eh bien il
abandonne la présidence du conseil
départemental de la manche
hermeline âme
à l'herbe et bien elle abandonne le
département des pyrénées-orientales
du côté des communistes on peut parler
d'éric bocquet qui ne sera plus maire de
marquise ou encore de vincent de l'est
centristes qui ne sera plus lui maire de
massy également du côté du groupe de la
république en marche
alain richard abandonne la mairie de
saint-ouen l'aumône
tout comme l'ancien ministre valérie
létard qui abandonne l la vice
présidence de la région des hauts de
france certains il faut le dire sont
aussi motivés par une future
interdiction celle du cumul des mandats
dans le temps puisque emmanuel macron a
déjà annoncé qu'il voulait qu'il ne
puisse pas être possible d'enchaîner
trois mandats d'affilée
philippe dallier par exemple lui en est
à son quatrième mandat de maire des
pavillons sous bois et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il préfère quitter sa
mairie et enfin tam les sénateurs non
renouvelables qui sont aussi impactés
par cette loi sur le non-cumul oui au
total selon le quotidien le monde si on
prend en compte l'ensemble des 348
sénateurs qui sont renouvelables au nom
et bien il avait tout de même cent
soixante sénateurs qui étaient concernés
par la loi sur le non cumul du mandat
beaucoup sont non renouvelable et
certains sont très médiatique ils ont
d'ailleurs annoncé leur décision au
cours des mois qui ont précédé par
exemple jean claude gaudin qui préfèrent
choisir à sa mairie de marseille
du côté du front national on peut
également parler de david rachline qui
lui préfère rester à la mairie de fréjus
al'inverse bruno retailleau seulement
moins de deux ans après avoir conquis la
présidence de la région des pays de la
loire et d'un lui préfère rester
sénateurs merci beaucoup un thème